the Assyrian located in Abydos Egypt
approximately 340 miles south of the
Great Pyramid of Giza is just another
example of a prehistoric civilization
because make no mistake the people
living in Egypt a few thousand years ago
also known as the ancient Egyptians
could not have constructed this site in
fact there's zero physical or scientific
evidence to even suggest that they did
and as you can see here this place is
absolutely incredible it's very hard to
appreciate just how massive these
granite blocks are until you have people
standing next to them which is a very
rare find in any picture because tours
of this site ended years ago due to
flooding and this site has been flooded
time and time again ever since it was
rediscovered in fact when they did find
it it was buried and as you can see here
here's a layout or a map of the site
which of course is referred to as a
temple isn't it funny how everything
from ancient times is always a temple
you also have to consider that when you
look at this site it once had a roof in
fact an incredibly impressive roof
system as you can see evidence of it
here but it was even double layered as
I'll be discussing here shortly you can
also see the doorways as this site
contains about a dozen chambers of some
kind and there are very few photos at
all in existence of this and these are
only a few that I could find and
unfortunately there's very little
information about this ancient site but
there's different artists renditions of
what it may have looked like before it
deteriorated or fell apart or was
destroyed you can see that there's some
sort of oval arch type circular
structure to the roofing system you can
see some evidence of here in this
black-and-white photo but one of the
truly amazing things about it is the
size and the weight of these granite
blocks and you can compare here as you
see these other pillars next to
comparison of the door and this is a
normal sized door so when you look at
these photos
you don't realize that many of these
pillars are eight feet by eight feet by
12 feet in height and it has been
estimated by engineers that with those
measurements 8 by 8 by 12 and assuming
175 pounds per cubic feet for the weight
of granite that these pillars are
approximately 67 tons a hundred and
thirty four thousand pounds apiece and
what makes it even crazier is the fact
that these were quarried from the Aswan
Quarry 200 miles away so how they move
these from 200 miles away is obviously a
mystery and there are different theories
on how they could have done this but
what makes it even more interesting is
how they lifted them into place as you
can see here they had interlocking
wedges as they stacked them on top of
each other and upon the closer look this
roofing system was double layered which
is incredible considering just how
massive these blocks are and then they
doubled them up why on earth would they
do that I mean this is some sort of bomb
shelter to suggest that this is a temple
for praying and to create a roofing
system like this and these pillars that
are as big as they are I think there's
more to this story but like I said at
the beginning of this video there's zero
physical or scientific evidence to
support that the ancient Egyptians have
constructed this site they did not have
the tooling these are examples of the
bronze and copper saws that the ancient
Egyptians did have as we found through
various archaeological digs but as you
can see in this photo this is the best
example of an Egyptian saw that is
remaining in fact there's so few that
have ever been found but when you look
at the measurements which I don't have
but just compare it to the handle the
blade itself must be less than 2 feet in
length so how on earth could the
Egyptians have cut a 12 foot by 8 by 8
granite block with something so small
mainstream Egyptologist and
archaeologists come up with various
theories on saws that they must have had
even saying that some of them may have
you been as big as 15 feet long but when
you look at evidence well there is none
there's not a single saw larger than the
one I just showed you and any kind ever
found throughout ancient Egypt nor are
there any type of pictures hieroglyphs
or petroglyphs that annotate any type of
saw larger than what you just found in
fact the only examples of picture
paintings that I have found from ancient
Egypt are these two which clearly show
that same type of saw cutting wood not
cutting stone and when these methods
have been tested they have failed
miserably no joke the best supporting
theory that Egyptologist and
archaeologists have are bronze slash
copper saws look at this quick video
it's less than a minute long where you
see mark Lehner himself one of the
leading authorities on ancient Egypt try
to demonstrate this to support the
argument that this is what the Egyptians
used just watch this video real quick
all right we have a big block of granite
here so how's this copper gonna cut this
granite even with teeth the copper alone
is too soft we're going to put sound
inside the groove and we're going to put
this saw on top of the sound and then
let the Sun do the cutting now Dennis
will we see any progress in our lifetime
yes if you came back in an hour's time
you would see about a full millimeter
cut down into it though you're kidding
in an hour you'll be four millimeters
down well I've been doing a lot of
experiments and I can guarantee that
this will cook through the stone that's
about one millimeter than our sorry went
wonderful once we switched over to using
water with the sand as you can see here
we achieve this in just a few days four
millimeters an hour are you joking and
although it went quicker with water what
does that mean was it twice as fast was
it eight millimeters an hour did they
even get an inch an hour because
according to the demonstration it could
not have and again they have never found
a saw this big they didn't find one with
these teeth marks on it either and it
filled miserably and even if it had
worked in at a rate of speed with the
precision have been there because these
stone blocks are unbelievably precise
and all the other methods outlined by
Egyptologists whether it be bronze
chisels stone hammers none of these
methods could work for this site not
even close now I'm not saying that the
ancient Egyptians could not have done
impressive things I mean take for
example the temple of hathor which is
unbelievably impressive and I'm gonna
make a video on this as well I have to
do more research on it but it seems to
me that the ancient Egyptians did
construct this site I again have to do
more research look how huge these
pillars are compared to people but keep
in mind that these are made of limestone
which is significantly easier to cut
than granite as well as far less heavy
but this is how they did it they did it
in sections which is very very similar
to how the ancient Greeks did this with
the Greek columns as you can see upon a
closer look that those were divided up
into sections as well
so although the temple of hathor is
unbelievably impressive it still does
not come
haier to what it would take to cut and
carve these stones located at the Syrian
so while doing research for this video I
came across a video from Chuck the
youtuber see faps seven eight six five
who have mentioned before and he
outlined in awesome detail instantly
this article that came out as you can
see here not even what two weeks ago
stating that this same location at
Abydos in Egypt they have found evidence
of through an archaeological dig dating
back 7,000 years and this article does a
few things wrong one they state that it
can be traced back to the first dynasty
which Chuck immediately picked up on and
realize that no according to all the
textbooks and everything we've been
taught the first dynasty of Egypt starts
at five thousand years ago so all of a
sudden two thousand years before that
and it's like not a big deal I mean
that's two thousand years earlier than
anything we've known about ancient Egypt
even a thousand years into prehistory as
we all know that the Sumerians history
starts with them as 6,000 years ago he
also noticed the water erosion on the
limestone enclosure around this facility
very very similar to that of the Great
Sphinx which proves the date being
significantly older but again Abydos
Egypt the Assyrian in the seven thousand
year old evidence so in other words if
there's already proof that people were
living here thousands of years to what
they already thought further evidence
that this was done by a prehistoric
civilization take a look at these photos
from the back wall of the Assyrian look
at these various cut marks and how they
closely resemble as you now see here
from Cusco Peru look at the type of cut
marks there and how similar they are but
it goes even further than that
look at these various knob marks that
you find from cusco to Egypt as well as
up in Machu Picchu which is very very
similar as you can see from these knob
marks located right here at the Assyrian
I mean is this all the coincidence
because there's actually more evidence
that would support that it's not a
coincidence and that they were a global
civilization look at the similarities
here between Machu Picchu and Egypt here
at the Assyrian and look at just how far
away that is separated by the Atlantic
Ocean practically on the other side of
the planet and the similarities don't
stop there whether it's comparison of
the various types of doors and
structures that they use the use of
trapezoidal doors the similarities of
structures I mean look at the shape of
the buildings I mean is that just a
coincidence the shape of the cut marks
or even just the very use of pyramids
across multiple continents look at these
photos right here isn't there a clear
difference between this stone wall which
clearly has utilized mortar mud mortar
and this is located right here in Peru
at Cusco and this other stone wall
located at the very same site the same
street there is absolute evidence of two
different civilizations and you can look
at other examples here at Machu Picchu
how they essentially the newer
civilization built on top of the older
but this is evidence that the older
civilization was more advanced and when
you go back over to the Assyrian you can
see the clear difference as it connects
to the temple of seti the absolute
difference between these sites the two
completely different types of technology
that were utilized to construct it and
to make it even more interesting the
Assyrian sits lower than the rest of the
site it's almost as if it's sunken down
or it was built so long ago as we know
that things that are older are further
down underground and the newer things at
the top right makes perfect sense and
that's exactly what you're seeing here
so here's what it comes down to as I
close this up the people living in Egypt
a few thousand years ago could not have
built this site there's zero evidence to
support it not one single tool has ever
been found ever to support that they
could have cut granite blocks especially
of this size nor have they ever found
any type of wall painting of any kind to
even suggest that they did have it and
we just haven't found it we have to
start connecting the dots on these
coincidences between the Incas or the
pre Incas I should say and the Egyptians
clearly this is further evidence that
there was a global civilization that
existed tens of thousands of years ago
and the evidence of this is so long
since gone except for these stone
structures that we see today again
there's more information about this site
that I'll be researching and looking
into so look forward to a part two but
I'll wrap it up there leave me a comment
let me know what your thoughts are I'm
Jimmy this is bright insight like and
subscribe and take care everybody